[Music]
valeri garcia's fans call him the
greatest conductor alive
[Music]
the russian maestro leads some of the
world's most famous orchestras
and he's a close friend of president
vladimir putin
[Applause]
he once said we are rich with not only
tchaikovsky do you remember
if a professional or a colleague told me
that i'd agree i'm pleased that the
country is led by a person who knows
that as well as us
supported russia's annexation of crimea
in 2014.
two years later he was criticized for
conducting a performance in the ancient
ruins of palmyra and syria
after russia helped the syrian
government retake the site from isil
now his silence on the invasion of
ukraine has led him to being removed
from concert in milan's la scala
and new york's carnegie hall
[Music]
and his manager says he can't represent
him as a client anymore
are the western cultural institutions
such as new york's metropolitan opera
have cut ties with pro-putin performers
we can no longer engage with artists or
institutions
and support putin or are supported by
him
not until the invasion and killing has
been stopped
order has been restored and restitutions
have been made
the decision could mean the end of the
mets partnership with moscow's bolshoi
ballet
and star soprano anana tripko who's due
to perform in april
she faced criticism when she was
photographed with a flag used by
russian-backed separatists in donetsk
social media netrepco called for the war
to end but said it was unfair to force
artists to voice political opinions and
denounce their homeland
others like these two russian and
ukrainian sopranos in naples decided to
use their performance as a gesture of
peace and friendship
as the war worsens it seems russia's
cultural figures will have to keep
making tough choices to stay in tune
with the public
priyanka gupta al-jazeera